you're one of the few people I believe
because you've always put your money
where your mouth is and this is why I
think you're the Godfather grunge you're
with the Buffalo Springfield wasn't it
those guys who said hey let's go on The
Tonight Show with Johnny Carson and you
say to them [ __ ] you we're not going on
that show it's too mainstream [ __ ] you
I'm not doing it Crosby Stills Nash and
Young one of the most successful albums
Deja Vu you say to yourself [ __ ] that I
want to go do my solo thing Spotify has
a podcast where they're putting out
information about a vaccine
you are on Spotify you make a lot of
money off of Spotify because your music
is one of the most streamed artists of
all time
you say wait a second Spotify do not put
shows on that put out false information
about the covet vaccine but you didn't
stop there you took your music off of
Spotify powered I woke up one morning
and somebody I heard somebody saying
there was some scientists
were saying something about covid or
some doctors
and and uh they were saying something
about covet and how many people were
dying in the hospitals and and
misinformation and you see all the
nurses and everything and these people
are with these people who are dying I
mean they're this is their life they're
they're that's what they do they try to
save people so these people were
distressed by the fact that Spotify
was doing this uh misinformation with
with some show they had and I I listened
to it and I said and and they were
saying he purposely is saying this stuff
that he knows isn't true about covid and
people are dying you know
and I just I I just called up my
management and said uh
we're we're out of there you know get me
off
and and we'll be fine but they're a
little shocky because they all know the
numbers and everything but I don't who
cares you know who cares I I you know
Neil that is such Integrity what is the
calculation how much money did you turn
down how many millions of dollars I
don't you didn't care you didn't care I
don't yeah I knew I was gonna do fine
were you shocked that more musicians not
not that they didn't agree with you but
they didn't step up and join your
boycott
no I I wasn't surprised because a lot of
people don't look at it like I look at
it
and their point of view is different
about it uh
I don't know why but the way I look at
it that just turned me off and I made an
instant decision I didn't think about it
at all I said just take my music off we
don't need it I've got all these other
places and and it sounds better at the
other places what why would I want to
keep it on Spotify when it sounds like
uh you know a pixelated movie but wasn't
it more than that Neil wasn't it the
idea that uh Hey it can either have Neil
Young
or you can have fake information going
out about the vaccine that's the way you
like it I I told him I said you can have
that guy or you can have me
you know take your choice so they chose
to have that guy because either making
millions of dollars off of them and
paying them they've just given them a
whole bunch of money and the whole thing
and and uh that I would just eventually
roll over and be back and you haven't
been I'm never going back there
or anywhere else like it I don't have to
I don't want to
foreign